nous on en a chié mais en même temps on
savait pourquoi ouais et alors que ceux
de maintenant ils ont aussi mis ça pas
pourquoi alors ils sont français
Rachid bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
le monde a parlé
vous êtes né le 18 septembre 1958 à Oran
à l'époque votre mère a 15 ans ce qui
fait que vous l'appelez pas maman mais
Aïcha quoi
vous emmène au hammam avec les cousines
avec les voisines s'abonner quoi super
ouais
alors enfance heureuse au bled le
souvenir le plus marquant vous dites
c'est l'odeur de mon grand-père maternel
une odeur de terre et de ciel
c'est l'auteur du sable c'est l'auteur
de la mémoire parce que le grand-père
c'est la mémoire
en 1968 donc vous avez 10 ans
traumatisé par la guerre d'indépendance
et la recherche de travail votre père se
résout à l'exil il s'installe en Alsace
à Sainte-Marie-aux-Mines
là il travaille dans le textile
de l'école on
crgs
alors le problème c'est comme il peut
pas vivre sans sa famille il vous
demande de le rejoindre 9 mois après et
là c'est le choc parce qu'il y a le
froid il y a la neige et la langue
la langue alsacienne c'est un changement
d'univers total totalement
le pire c'est le racisme des enfants qui
répètent ce qu'ils entendent le soir à
la maison
le racisme des enfants c'est un peu
c'est comme les charcuteries tu vois
c'est donc ils mangent du saucisson mais
ça peut le découper donc ils entendent
des conneries mais en même temps ils
sont pas si racistes que ça parce que
quand je vais au football avec eux je
tire le président du quartier ouais
ouais voilà c'est pas heureusement le
foot vous permet de vous intégrer le
foot il rentre de bol ouais
alors quand l'usine est votre père
travaille ferme vous partez dans les
Vosges à l'éponge sur Vologne mais c'est
la famille Villemin il est peut-être
aller à l'école avec les humains
dans une ville qui s'appelle bruyère
j'étais d'abord ce qu'on appelle une
école républicaine puis après bon ils
m'ont mis en transition et mon père
voulait absolument que je fasse un petit
diplôme il m'a mis dans une école
catholique les bonnes soeurs oui votre
père était très stricte sur l'éducation
ils ont européenne vous êtes la seule
famille du quartier à avoir une table
haute pour manger alors que la plupart
manger sur des tables basses comme
il y avait ce côté un peu occidental
parce que lorsqu'on a hérité de ce qu'on
appelait en Algérie depuis un wagons il
y avait des tables qui restait de se
décolons qui sont partis et on avait des
fourchettes donc on avait des chaises
donc voilà et un grand lit
vous êtes un peu turbulent vous met chez
les bonnes soeurs ça s'est passé comment
super enfin super
mais c'est bien parce que je devais
passer mes diplômes et finalement
turbulent mais assez assidu quand même
premier en catéchisme c'est pas mal
toujours
parce que je me suis toujours intéressé
à l'histoire et la théologie tout ça
donc l'islam la Bible Coran les judaïsme
et tout pour moi c'est à votre père
était allé à l'école coranique qui
maîtrisait le Coran mais vous avez dans
la dans la tolérance en fait tellement
c'est ça les vrais musulmans
pas les nouveaux donc une connaissance
que je vois de temps en temps qui parle
l'arabe de gauche à droite
alors vous dites d'ailleurs en parlant
de tolérance vous savez qu'on enseigne
guerre le low cost aux petits arabes de
peur qu'il détestent un peu moins les
juifs
ou des écrivains palestinés qui le
disent donc comme j'aime l'histoire et
je pense que l'histoire c'est ce qui
nous fait avancer je pense qu'il faut
apprendre aux gens la véritable histoire
il faut pas non plus négliger comme il
faut apprendre la véritable histoire
c'est pas destiniens des Alsaciens des
Irakiens de ce qui se passe en Irak tout
ce qui se passe à Gaza etc je pense que
la mémoire est importante
vous dites moi je maintiens qu'un pays
sans forte communauté juive est un pays
où la démocratie risque de mourir parce
qu'ils savent discuter réfléchir sans
fin ça fait partie intégrante de leur
étude du Talmud parce que je pense que
l'Afrique du Nord l'Afrique du Nord on a
toujours une présence juive
dans le monde entier je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très important pour je
pense que c'est important d'avoir toutes
les communautés du monde parce que ça ça
enrichit les uns et les autres l'autre
enrichit d'autres moi j'existe qu'à
travers toi et toi tu existes à travers
moi donc parfois ça me manque le voisin
en 1977 le fils du maire de l'éponge
vous embarque pour vendre avec lui des
encyclopédies médicales en
porte-à-portements on voulait gagner des
étoiles on n'est pas gagné de l'argent
mais en disant vous gagnez des étoiles
pour aller dans le ciel
et là vous utilisez votre chat pour le
commerce il prenait l'accent
Alberto Sordi que d'Homer donc bon
c'était un peu pour
la timidité à cause de
j'utilisais un rôle je prenait un rôle
alors vous allez faire VRP pendant deux
ans et puis vous partez rejoindre votre
famille qui s'est installée à Lyon et là
vous entrez à l'usine thermique où vous
montez les radiateurs
je travaillais avec des mongoliens dans
la grève qui faisaient les fours les
jouets majorettes puis après j'ai
travaillé j'avais la croix
toutes les usines du quartier de toute
façon on peut être bureau quand
j'arrivais auprès de comptabilité il
fallait soit avoir le rester française
soit avoir du métier alors tu sais pour
avoir le métier
alors le reste du temps vous écoutez de
la musique alors il y a les chanteurs
que votre père cherche comme ça sur la
radio comme pendant la guerre quoi alors
il y a home calsum Farid El Atrache il y
a les cassettes de rail que votre mère
écoute dans la cuisine et puis vous vous
écoutez tous les groupes de rock à
commencer par les Zeppelin
procolarum gang enfin tout tout ce qui
se passe à la radio
alors c'est à l'usine thermique que vous
rencontrez les frères Amini Mohamed et
Mokhtar alors il joue de la guitare
percussionniste sur des casseroles mais
vous dites je suis batteur
et on cherchait un nom et puis bon on a
trouvé garde aussi et voilà en 1983
votre premier vrai album sort ça
s'appelle roromani et ses produits par
stevil Edge c'est bien
alors mais c'est pas facile parce que
les magasins refusent le CD carte de
séjour Europe 1 vous boycott je sais pas
qui c'est qui disait bon il y en a marre
de passer des [__] sur la sur la
chaîne
il y avait même un concert à la Scala
qui était annulé c'est difficile à
l'époque
actuellement avec la nouvelle génération
c'est nous on en a chié mais en même
temps on savait pourquoi et alors que ce
maintenant ils ont aussi mis
en 1986 donc votre reprise de 12 France
de Charles Trenet fait un carton c'était
énorme d'ailleurs
de leur parler de nationalité parce que
certains voulaient revenir sur le droit
du sang au droit du sol donc on s'est
dit mais arrêtez pourquoi dès que ça
concerne les rebeux c'est vrai qu'il y a
en France faut pas se cacher pour
certains la garde Algérie n'est pas
finie donc dès qu'il s'agit de
immigrés d'origine arabe
il y a tout de suite un problème alors
après évidemment douce France vous
devenez célèbre parce que ça marche très
bien tout le monde est impressionné par
ce morceau comment réagit votre votre
entourage votre père et la réagi comment
va très bien
ça c'est un peu moins bien passé c'est à
dire que en fait Jacques Martin est le
seul qui vous fait passer à la télé
pour moi c'est désolé mais pour moi
c'est l'un des amis l'animateur le plus
le plus turbulent et le plus le plus
cool de l'époque parce que certains dès
que le mec les appeler ah non on peut
pas vous savez Jacques Martin il se
trouve
là c'est pas grave
pas du tout c'était dur hein
j'en ai commencé à gagner un peu après
avec 1 2 3 soleil tout ça et puis les
tourner que j'ai fait parce que j'en
étais pas mal est-ce que cette célébrité
soudaine nous a rapporté l'amour au
moins ouais bien sûr totalement beaucoup
de conquêtes
beaucoup de conquêtes
des conquêtes de qualité c'est pas le
nombre qui compte
la qualité quel était le meilleur moment
de toute cette époque Rachid le fait de
faire un album d'enregistrer un disque
comme ça on était des gamins quand même
ça c'est génial on est dans une maison
de disque et le pire moment
c'est le pire moment aussi parce que des
fois tu sais pas comment le gérer
alors carte de séjour se sépare en 1989
au moment de la chute du mur de Berlin à
Berlin exactement
et ensuite faites une carrière solo
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque carte de séjour non non parce
que ça m'a permis de faire ce que je
suis en train de faire je vais de la
rancune contre quelqu'un
faire
j'ai pas le temps je regarde de l'avant
j'ai pas le temps d'avoir de la langue
et si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil
ben peut-être j'aurais peut-être au lieu
de dire car de ces jours je ne serai
appelé Fugees
[Rires]
merci Rachid c'est très heureux de
rallumer la lumière et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu